233 en Loir-et-Cher et 383 en
Indre-et-Loire c'est le nombre de
médecins pour 100.000 habitants au 1er
janvier 2022 des statistiques fournies
par l'INSEE pas de quoi se réjouir car
notre région est celle où les médecins
sont les moins nombreux pourtant des
initiatives peuvent changer la donne 5e
et dernier volet de notre série de la
semaine consacrée à la santé direction
Saint-Georges-sur-Cher un habitant de un
village de 2600 habitants là-bas ont
comptabilise 8 médecins généralistes le
dernier arrivé à lancer son activité en
début de semaine romain Delville
cet après-midi ces jours d'installation
d'un nouveau médecin à la maison de
santé de Saint-Georges-sur-Cher il y a
pas mal de spécialités qui se
développent dans ces hôpitaux là et qui
sont pas loin qui sont à 20 minutes
d'ici ça se fait dans le sens le jeune
praticien devient le 8e médecin
généraliste installé ici je suis passé
ici dans cette maison de santé en tant
que en tant qu'interne il y a six mois
justement pour mon dernier stage et donc
j'ai vu que l'ambiance était bonne que
ça se passait bien j'ai appris à
connaître tout le monde les locaux et ça
facilite vachement l'installation quoi
pour l'accueillir le maire de la commune
qui est aussi vice-président à la santé
de la communauté de communes Val de Cher
comptoir Jacques Paoletti ne s'en cache
pas
Saint-Georges-sur-Cher et privilégié en
termes de démographie médicale
des situations très contrastées sur ce
territoire du Val de Chartres 50 000
habitants en bas de
Saint-Georges-sur-Cher à celles-sur-cher
de Saint-Aignan à contre voilà les
situations sur la la la démographie
médicale et pas la même donc on essaie
de s'adapter pour accompagner le
professionnel dans son installation ses
démarches administratives l'agence
d'attractivité du Loir-et-Cher a
désormais un chargé de mission au petit
soin on travaille en amont avec le
professionnel de santé sur vraiment son
projet et ses besoins et du coup en
fonction de tout ce qui souhaite
notamment en termes d'exercices de lieu
d'exercice et après d'accompagnement
pour sa famille on fait des propositions
de lieu qui correspondent et après on
organise une visite sur une journée en
général où on lui fait rencontrer tous
les lieux sélectionnés un suivi qui
dépasse largement le cadre professionnel
des seuls médecins le dispositif est
aussi les conjoints à trouver un travail
ou une formation